So let's look at our first function, f of x equals 2x plus 3. The domain is all
real numbers, as is the range. And, this function is neither even nor odd.
Let's look at our second function, f of x equals x squared plus 6. Our domain
is again all real numbers. Our range is y greater than or equal to 6. And this
is an even function. let's look at f of x equals negative 2. Our domain is again
all real numbers, but our range is restricted to y is equal to negative 2. And
this is an even function. let's look at f of x equals x cubed minus 1. The
domain is all real numbers, as is the range, and this is neither even nor odd.
Let's look at the function f of x equals the absolute value of x minus 2. The
domain is all real numbers. The range is y is greater than or equal to 0. And
this is neither even nor an odd function. Our last function, f of x equals the
square root of 3 x plus 2. Our domain is x is greater than or equal to 2 3rds.
Our range, y greater than or equal to 0. And again, this is neither even nor an
odd function.